I'm going to talk to you today about
evaluation metrics and I have two
reasons for that one is that my own
background how I came into machinery was
from a different industry from software
development and so I had to learn a lot
of the things on my own and machine
learning metrics what was one of the
topics that was a little bit confusing
because there are tons of them and how
are they different
when should I choose which one so I had
to Google a lot and if you are like me
entering the field from a different
background I'm hoping to save you some
time and so I hope to summarize what
these are and how you can use them and
another reason for this talk is that
evaluation metrics are something that
you use to ultimately decide which
machinery model you're gonna use in
production which model is gonna be used
in real world effecting decisions
affecting sometimes human lives and this
is a metric that you rely on so it is in
my opinion essential to understand how
they work what's the difference between
them so because you're gonna be using it
as a tool in your work a lot so what's
an evaluation metric just so we are on
the same page evaluation metric is a way
to quantify performance of a machine
learning model so when we train a
machine learning model we don't want it
to simply memorize the training data we
want it to be able to generalize so we
wanted to be giving good predictions on
the data that it has not seen and we
need a way to quantify that so we
usually don't train just one model we
tune hyper parameters which write
different algorithms we try different
maybe sets of features and then again we
need to compare the performance of all
those models and choose the one that
we're going to use so now we know what
it is and why we need it there are
different techniques of evaluating a
machine
in models performance but high-level
idea is that you somehow train the
machinery model on one set of data and
you keep another set of data that the
machine learning model was did not see
so you can evaluate that performance and
you can have holdout or train test split
technique where you essentially split
the data in different chunks and there
are also different approaches to that
randomly splitting or keeping the last
in time data for the test and there are
many techniques to do so if you don't
have that much data you may need to do
cross-validation and it is essentially
kind of like a repeated holdout when you
just split the data train evaluate split
again in a different fashion
train evaluate again and then average
the metric there are also different ways
of choosing an optimal set of hyper
parameters there's a straightforward
grid search there is typical option
there are different optimized algorithms
and tools like hyper rot for example to
choose over the space of hyper
parameters but then again ultimately
you're trying to find the one model with
certain set of parameters that are
they're gonna give you the best value
for the metric that you have chosen and
in this talk I'm gonna talk about
supervised learning metrics and these
are the ones that I'm going to cover
there's more but these are these are the
ones that I consider essential and these
are the ones that are most commonly used
and as you know in supervised learning
there are two categories of problems we
have classification and we have
regression problems and they have
different sets of metrics and I'm gonna
start with classification metrics and to
make things a little bit simpler first
we're just gonna limit this to binary
classification that's where you decide
whether the pictures of a hot dog or not
hot dog if you're familiar with the ref
so the first metric we you normally will
encounter is classification accuracy of
course and it is very straightforward
it's very intuitive and easy to
understand
so how many predictions were correct out
of the whole number of predictions and
I'm gonna be showing examples in
scikit-learn but any machine learning
model sorry any machine learning library
is going to have there its own set of
metrics available to you and in
scikit-learn let's say I trained some
simple logistic regression on some data
and there is a score method that is
that's gonna give you the accuracy as a
default evaluation metric for any
classification in scikit-learn so in
this case I get 96% accuracy and it may
seem great but except from this example
we don't know really if it's a good
accuracy or not and to illustrate this I
took the same data and I trained a dummy
classifier on the same data in
scikit-learn
a dummy classifier is a classifier that
doesn't learn anything from the data but
it follows some strategy in this case
let me see if I can in this Coop's
anyway in this case my strategy is to
predict always the most frequent label
in the training data but there are other
strategies - you can for example
generate predictions uniformly at random
and there are two I think more
strategies there and I can use dummy
classifiers as a sanity check and they
have all the same let's say methods and
properties like regular classifiers so I
can for example use a score method on it
and I get ninety four point two percent
accuracy and this is
not doesn't it seems like something was
really wrong with my model because it's
only well it wasn't he was doing a
little bit better than a dummy
classifier and the reason is in the data
of course I simply generated this data
with 10,000 examples where only 5% are
of the positive class and this is what
is called a class imbalanced data set
and these are quite common
whenever you're classifying some rare
events you can have more examples of the
normal events or then for normal
examples whatever that may mean
and in this case accuracy is gonna give
you false impression that your model is
doing amazing when in reality that may
not necessarily be the case so while
it's very easy to understand it may be
confusing and accuracy alone will not
help you will not help you diagnose the
errors that your model is making and
it's not gonna help you address those
errors but of course we have a lot more
diagnostic tools and other evaluation
metrics and I'm gonna start with
confusion matrix which is not a metric
but it's a very useful diagnostic tool
to gain insight into the type of errors
your model is making and it also is
useful to understand how other metrics
work because we can get them from their
confusion matrix so this time I took
Titanic dataset from Kaggle where the
goal is to predict survival of the
passengers skipping all the data cleanup
and feature engineering skipping all the
work here is a basic random forest
classifier it gives me eighty three
point four point four percent accuracy
and I can import confusion matrix from
scikit-learn dot matrix I can give it
the test data
and the predicted values from this model
and then I get back this beautiful array
with numbers if for those people who see
it for the first time it can be
confusing what does it mean so typically
people and illustrate confusion matrix
they draw it as a table like that it
makes it a lot easier to understand
what's going on here so by convention in
scikit-learn and it is the same in
tensorflow and some other libraries you
get the actual true labels in the rows
and the predicted values labels in the
columns but there are different
libraries that have it the other way
around so if you're reading some
articles and you're looking at results
be careful and take note that what that
convention with that specific library or
in that article is because it can be you
can be seen one thing but it's actually
different thing in there so what can we
get from this confusion matrix who
doesn't know what false positive or two
negative is nobody perfect so this is
what we can get from the confusion
matrix and we can also get the accuracy
from it if we just sum up what's on the
green diagonal and divide by the sum of
everything in all the cells but there
are other matrix that we can get from
the confusion matrix and let's start
with an example let's say we are
building a classic example spam filter
in which case spam is a positive class
and we want to reduce the number of
false positives because the false
positive in that case means that I have
a very very important email about my
promotion maybe and it goes into the
junk folder and that makes me really
unhappy as a user so fishing out
important emails out of a spam box is
not a good user experience
there are many examples of that
typically when it's something user
facing system recommendations that are
not relevant to you and that sort of
thing so in this case I want to have as
many false positives as possible and
there is a metric that can help me with
that
it's called precision the formula is
very simple it's number of true
positives divided by true positives plus
false positives and as you can imagine
the smaller the number of false
positives the better the metric now if
on the other hand we care about false
negatives we only want to so we for
example predicting a cancer diagnosis or
something like that and it is safer to
send a person who is healthy to take a
few more tests than to miss that
diagnosis and Senate person home the
risks are higher here if we do not
predict this negative outcome so in this
case there's a very very similar matrix
called recall that allows us to focus on
the false negatives and it works the
same way you have less false negatives
the metric gets better the one tricky
part about these two metrics at least
for me as I was starting in machine
learning was to remember which ones
which and to me what it helped to think
of that precision starts with P and it's
all about positive true positives false
positives and recall is the other one so
I hope that maybe help will be helpful
to someone else too and then of course
we have another way of summarizing their
confusion matrix in one metric and it's
called f1 score that allows us to take
into account both precision and recall
and it's essentially just a harmonic
mean of the two so when you're choosing
a metric to evaluate your machinery
model not only the shape of the data is
important but also what is your business
problem what are the
important types of errors that he maybe
want to put more focus on so if you care
about minimizing false positives you may
want to monitor the precision of the
models and if you care about minimizing
false negatives then you need recall so
a lot depends on the data and on your
business problem in scikit-learn we can
get these metrics from the same module
as confusion matrix so scikit-learn dot
matrix and then for this particular case
I get different precision recall and f1
score and if I want to search through
hyper parameters for example with a grid
search I can easily do this and I can
say I want to find a model find hyper
parameters for this model that will give
me a good recall the best recall and you
can do this by specifying scoring
parameter for the grid search and in
this case it I got a little small
improvement accuracy and f1 score are
not the only ways to summarize a
confusion matrix in one metric there is
also Matthews correlation coefficient
how many of you are familiar all right
it's another way to summarize the matrix
and this is the formula the only thing I
want you to notice about this formula is
that it takes into account all four
cells of the confusion matrix and that
has important side effects let's compare
it with f1 score first I'm gonna take a
very very artificial example I have my
data of 100 samples 95 of them positive
5 negative and I have a dummy classifier
so accuracy is going to be 95% I'm
always predicting that is positive and
this is what f1 score is gonna be just
doing the maths here and it's actually
even a little bit better but if I try to
calculate MCC scikit-learn is gonna give
me a zero and a big red warning because
I'm dividing by zero and it's undefined
and it's so far the only metric that is
giving me any indication that
something's wrong going on here but you
can say hey well you know it's that my
classifier it's and we're not real thing
so how often this is gonna happen okay
let's take a different example so now I
have the same data right but I have a
slightly better model and I managed to
predict I have some to negative some
true positives some false negatives and
positives I get f1 score a little bit
lower
I get MCC 0.135 but what I'm gonna do
now I'm gonna say so what I was calling
a positive example I'm gonna call a
negative example and the other way
around
so I'm just gonna switch what I call a
positive class and what I call a
negative class and calculate and the
model is the same the predictions are
exactly the same what happens is so the
confusion MAGIX is going to be a little
bit different but the model is
essentially still the same
MCC stays the same but f1 score changes
drastically and this is exactly because
MCC takes into account all four cells of
the confusion matrix while f1 score
it's a harmonic mean of precision and
recall in neither precision or recall
take into account false which one false
negatives right so that makes f1 score
very sensitive to what you call a
positive example and what you call a
negative example and all things
considered I find MCC to be a better way
to summarize a confusion
tricks when you have a binary problem
unfortunately it's quite hard to extend
it to a multi-class problem so there are
limitations to that but so far we've
looked at metrics that only take into
account weather prediction was correct
or not but of course a lot of classifier
classifiers the output probabilities of
a sample be belonging to a positive
class or to a negative class and there
of course metrics and diagnostic tools
that take that into account so one of
those things one of the Diagnostics
tools is ROC curve and our assistance
for receiver operating characteristic
which doesn't help to understand it but
what it is is a plot where on the x axis
you have false positive rate and on the
y axis is a true positive rate and
before I was talking so a model has one
precision one recall why is it a curve
that's because we have probabilities and
when we have probabilities we have a
certain threshold where we decide we can
label it as a positive class or we're
going to label it as a negative class
and we can move that probability sorry
the threshold and say we are going to
only classify the sample as a positive
class if the probability is higher than
90% so what we can do here we move this
threshold and for each threshold we
recalculate the true positive rate and
false positive rate and then we get all
these dots we get this curve and we want
it to be really really close to upper
left corner because if you think about
if we have a threshold at some threshold
at which we perfectly classify
everything then the false positive rate
it's going to be zero true positive rate
is going to be one so it's going to be
in that upper left corner and as we move
the threshold we're going to get the
lines along the upper boundary and left
boundary but this is not a number so we
cannot really we can visually inspect
different
models but for a metric winning the
number and we can get the number very
easily au C stands for area under curve
it's essentially how much of this box is
under this curve and and if you have a
really good perfect
ROC it's going to be one because it's
gonna be the whole box so that's not the
only curve that you can use there's also
precision recall curve and this is a
very similar thing except now on access
you have precision and recall how are
they different well it comes back to
imbalance data so the same example with
class imbalance data we take
probabilities and we plug both curves
and as you can see ROC gives me a score
of 0.92 when precision the recall curve
is going to give me only fifty seven
point seven percent so again when you're
dealing with class and balanced datasets
ROC curve may not be ideal and you may
want to add some other metrics or maybe
a look at precision recall curve instead
of course there's also log loss and this
magic is good because it takes into
account the probabilities and it is also
often used both as a loss function and
as a valuation metric which is great
because that's something that you're
already optimizing for so a loss
function takes into account the
uncertainty of model predictions and it
penalize is wrong classifications but
more importantly it gives higher
penalties to predictions that are not
only wrong but also very confident in
their predictions and it is I would say
very close to accuracy in the sense that
when you minimize the log loss the
accuracy is going to be increasing
- so this is what a it would look like
on a very very simple example so we have
a label a true label that predicted
probability of class 1 and the log loss
so as you can see if the to label is 1
and predicted probability of the sample
belonging to class 1 is very high the
log loss is quite low but the more wrong
the model is and more confident the
model is and its predictions the log
loss tends to skyrocket there but just
like the accuracy
it gives equal weight to all the samples
so again in class and balanced scenario
you may want to add some more metrics
here now how do this extend to multi
class scenario you still can use
confusion matrix in this case you still
it's better to visualize it because it
becomes a lot harder to understand
what's where and you still have true
labels on the rows and predicted labels
on in the columns in this case it's a
digits data set so numbers from 1 to 9
are actually the labels and you still
get the diagonal with the correct
predictions but now you can actually see
what labels were misclassified for what
and diagnose and maybe look into those
samples but now we don't really have the
notion of true positive and negative
it's no longer it's no longer a binary
problem but we can calculate metrics
such as precision recall and f1 score to
do that we need to treat the problem as
a collection of binary plot problems one
versus all we calculate these metrics
per label and then we average them and
as you can see there are different ways
of averaging so you get macro averaging
micro averaging and weighted averaging
and you're gonna get different results
even on this very very simple example so
what's this
between these ways of averaging let's
take this example first I'm going to
convert it into a confusion matrix now
for this confusion matrix I'm going to
write down the numbers of true positives
and what positives I'm only going to do
precision because the other ones are
going to be exactly the same so for the
class bird true positives are every time
when it was a bird and we predicted a
bird it's only that one cell in the
corner false positives are gonna be all
the times when we said it was a bird but
it was not so everything in that column
except for that cell we were when we
were right so we sum it up and well
false negatives would have been every
time we said it was not it was something
else
doesn't matter what but it was actually
a bird so it would be this whole row
summed up without that self and we do it
for each and every class in the end I
write down the total number of true
positives and false positives now I can
calculate precision for each class
individually so for the bird it's gonna
be one for the cat 0.8 and so on I'm
also going to add here the number of
samples and now micro precision is going
to be calculated just from the totals so
in this case all the samples get taken
into account in equal matter micro
precision is going to be simply the
average of per class precision in this
case every class contributes equally to
the metric it doesn't matter how big or
small it is and the weighted precision
is calculated by taking into account the
sizes so the number of samples within
each class so we get a slightly
different metric so which one do you
choose
again micro average every sample is
equally contributes to the average and
micro average
is when all classes equally contribute
to the average weighted average is when
each classes contribution to the average
is weighted by its size so for example
if you have again class imbalance data
set and if you have some classes that
are more important to get right you may
want to go for a micro average to
amplify the contribution of
underrepresented classes scikit-learn
documentation recommends using micro
averaging for multi-label problems and
in other cases you can also go for
weighted average there's of course of
course also multi class log loss and it
is a broader case of a binary log loss
in fact it's actually the other way
around the binary case is a sub class of
multi class log loss if you are like me
coming from software background and
looking at this formula and thinking
like what's that it helps to think of it
as a for loop so I wrote it down here as
a for loop essentially we take for each
label we take a binary indicator whether
it's the right label for this sample and
then multiply it by the log of
probability of this label being the
right for the this sample and we sum it
up of course in scikit-learn there's a
different important implementation
vectorized and optimize and all that but
just to understand how it works for me
for example is that it helps to think of
it as a for loop in a for loop now let's
switch to regression metrics I find that
regression metrics are a lot easier than
classification matrix in the sense that
you don't have multiple possible
versions of an answer
we're not dealing we're only dealing
with continuous value and we don't have
probabilities to deal with so it gets a
lot easier we just have continuous value
we have predicted continuous value we
subtract one from the other we get the
error
or residual and now we just need to
figure out a way how to use all
individual individual errors in combine
them into one metric that's going to
give us the idea of what's going on in
scikit-learn all regressors have a
default scoring method default
evaluation metric so if for a
classification was accuracy and four
regressors it's R squared R squared
indicates how well the model predictions
approximate the true values where one is
a perfect fit and zero is a dummy
regress or predicting the average and
this is how it's calculated so one minus
this scary thing in the numerator you
essentially have all the squared errors
summed up and in the denominator the sum
of distance squared distances between
the actual value and the mean of actual
values so if you have a dummy regressor
the top and the bottom are going to be
the same you're gonna have R squared of
zero you can go into negatives as well
if you predict in really really large
numbers which are make no sense at all
the good thing about is that it has
intuitive skills in order to accuracy
kind of like a percentage value and it
does not depend on the units whether
it's prices distance whatever it is it
doesn't matter but it also doesn't give
you any information about the predictive
error and for example if it's prices
your sake holder is probably care about
how many exactly dollars this is gonna
be and what's the prediction error but
there are metrics of course they're
going to help you with that the first
one the easiest one is the mean absolute
error it's essentially just the mean of
these absolute errors it's very straight
forward it's leaner and then we also
have mean squared error very similar to
absolute instead now we just square the
errors and take the average of that
the only thing with this metric is that
it's gonna you know if you have a large
error it's gonna square it so it's gonna
be huge and this is not always desirable
so that's why we have root mean squared
error and it's also often used as a loss
function so this is just mean squared
error and you take a root out of this
this is one of the most commonly used
metrics but every now and then people
are asking themselves so it is a good is
it a good metric or maybe we should do
the absolute error because there's you
know we squaring the error so how
adequate is that and they do have a lot
of in common they range from 0 to
infinity they have the same units as Y
values as the targets they don't care
about the direction of the errors and
you want this magic to be as low as
possible but their differences are MSE
gives really high way to large errors
and mean absolute error is more robust
to outliers because it doesn't square
the errors are MSE is differentiable but
it doesn't really matter in this context
because we are not applying this during
the training we only applying it
afterwards and I've seen a lot of
articles arguing about which one is
better I think the ones who say that
absolute error is better based on the
paper from 2005 by Willman and Matsuura
they argued that our MSE is an
appropriate and misinterpreted measure
of average error but then you know 4
years later there was not a paper that
said actually that's not the case and
RMS is perfectly fine in all the
practical cases in our army C is
actually perfectly valid metric to be
used but you know the older paper
sometimes still gets quoted but neither
of the magic metrics is going to be a
robust on a small test set so if you
have very few example not
of them is gonna make for a robust
metric sometimes I also use this one a
version of Armas II root means square
logarithmic error and it's very similar
to our MSE but it uses natural logarithm
of y plus 1 instead of y plus 1 is just
because the log of 0 is not defined and
it shows relative error and it helps
with scale for example you have again
prices you have $50 prices and you have
$50,000 prices $5 error is going to be
very very different for this two
different examples so you want to scale
that so and log helps you do that so
it's gonna be very very useful you can
scale the targets as well and then use
rmse or you can use this metric so one
or the other this metric tends to
penalize under a predicted estimates
more than over predicted that depends on
the contest if you want normally I
haven't seen an example where it married
too much one metric I want to show you
that business people really like and
this is mean absolute percentage error
this one shows well essentially your
error what percent of the actual value
it is on average and this is just very
easy to understand in the presentations
business people tend to ask about this
kind of thing but it's very problematic
if you have you cannot use it if your
targets can be zeros because you're
dividing by 0 in this case and it has a
lot of issues when the targets are
really small so you have to be careful
with it but sometimes it comes in handy
and before I I'm gonna wrap it up I'm
gonna give you a couple of warnings and
these are
any metric is going to be only a proxy
to what you really want to measure and
we've seen an example where examples of
when a metric is not necessarily the
best choice when you decide that the
viewers of your video content are going
to be happy if they watch more and then
you see the rise of you know conspiracy
theories promoted weird content and that
sort of thing so how you define success
how you choose what you measure and
that's gonna affect also the metric and
you have to be conscious about that and
another thing is metrics can be gamed so
in the keynote yesterday the keynote
speaker mentioned that they're
considering the ways how they can game
the Spotify algorithm to get their
clients show up on a playlist and
everywhere a system is where everywhere
possible really if people are gonna try
to gain metrics and where some also
political news around that you when some
content from specific countries showed
up in their algorithms more higher
higher than you know the content from
trusted sources let's say so metrics can
be gamed and they're not the ultimate
truth for everything so that's something
to keep in mind as well now there is no
one metric that's gonna fit all your
cases you have to be careful which
metric you choose depending on your data
depending on your business objective and
what exactly you are trying to optimize
for what your success looks like and as
with everything else you need to apply
common sense and where possible invite
domain experts who are going to be able
to give their opinion on whether your
metric
actually makes any sense in this
particular contact [ __ ] context I'm
gonna publish my slides on Twitter and I
have a bunch of links in there if you
want to read some more and if we have
time I think I can take some questions
thank you so I was wondering if there
are metric and symbols like the way
there are model and symbols that's a
good question
[Music]
well I get I guess
well you certainly could do this but you
would have to be like you could do that
on your own and you would have to define
how some metrics may be way more or less
there I don't think there is a kind of a
standard approach to this so that may
make sense in under some circumstances
but that would be very specific to
whatever you are trying to do so I'm not
aware of standard techniques for that or
you could do that just just like try to
figure out how would you do this
and then the problem with that it's
going to be harder to interpret than
each individual metric on its own that's
for sure and whatever logic you built
into that you'll have to unroll that
when understanding what's happening I
don't see any hands
so I guess thank you all right
you